amazon web services launched in 2006
with a total of three products
storage buckets compute instances and a
messaging queue
today it offers a mind-numbing 200 and
something services
and what's most confusing is that many
of them appear to do almost the exact
same thing it's kind of like shopping at
a big grocery store where you have
different aisles of product categories
filled with things to buy that meet the
needs of virtually every developer
on the planet in today's video we'll
walk down these aisles to gain an
understanding of over 50 different aws
products so first let's start with a few
that are above my paygrade that you may
not know exist
if you're building robots you can use
robomaker to simulate and test your
robots at scale
then once your robots are in people's
homes you can use iot core to collect
data from them
update their software and manage them
remotely if you happen to have a
satellite orbiting earth you can tap
into amazon's global network of antennas
to connect data through its ground
station service
and if you want to start experimenting
and researching the future of computing
you can use bracket to
interact with a quantum computer but
most developers go to the cloud to solve
more practical problems and for that
let's head to the compute aisle one of
the original aws products was
elastic compute cloud it's one of the
most fundamental building blocks on the
platform and allows you to create a
virtual computer in the cloud
choose your operating system memory and
computing power
then you can rent that space in the
cloud like you're renting an apartment
that you pay for by the second a common
use case is to use an instance as a
server for web application
but one problem is that as your app
grows you'll likely need to distribute
traffic
across multiple instances in 2009 amazon
introduced elastic load balancing which
allowed developers to distribute traffic
to multiple instances
automatically in addition the cloudwatch
service can collect
logs and metrics from each individual
instance the data collected from
cloudwatch can then be passed off to
auto scale
in which you define policies that create
new instances as they become needed
based on the traffic and utilization of
your current infrastructure these tools
were revolutionary at the time
but developers still wanted an easier
way to get things done
and that's where elastic bean stock
comes in most developers in 2011 just
wanted to deploy a ruby on rails app
elastic beanstalk
made that much easier by providing an
additional layer of abstraction
on top of ec2 and other auto scaling
features
choose a template deploy your code and
let all the auto scaling stuff happen
automatically
this is often called a platform as a
service but in some cases
it's still too complicated if you don't
care about the underlying infrastructure
whatsoever
and just want to deploy a wordpress site
lightsail is an alternative option where
you can point and click at what you want
to deploy and worry even less about the
underlying configuration in all these
cases you are deploying a static server
that is always running in the cloud
but many computing jobs are ephemeral
which means they don't rely
on any persistent state on the server so
why bother deploying a server for code
like that
in 2014 lambda came out which are
functions as a service
or serverless computing with lambda you
simply upload your code
then choose an event that decides when
that code should run
traffic scaling and networking are all
things that happen entirely in the
background and unlike a dedicated server
you only pay for the exact number of
requests and computing time that you use
now if you don't like writing your own
code you can use the serverless
application repository
to find pre-built functions that you can
deploy with the click of a button
but what if you're a huge enterprise
with a bunch of its own servers outpost
is a way to run aws apis on your own
infrastructure without needing to throw
your old servers in the garbage
in other cases you may want to interact
with aws from remote or extreme
environments like if you're a scientist
in the arctic snow devices are like
little mini data centers that can work
without internet and hostile
environments
so that gives us some fundamental ways
to compute things but many apps today
are standardized with docker containers
allowing them to run on multiple
different clouds or computing
environments with very little effort
to run a container you first need to
create a docker image and store it
somewhere elastic container registry
allows you to upload an image
allowing other tools like elastic
container service to pull it back down
and run it ecs is an api for starting
stopping and allocating virtual machines
to your containers
and allows you to connect them to other
products like load balancers
some companies may want more control
over how their app scales in which case
eks is a tool for running kubernetes but
in other cases you may want your
containers to behave
in a more automated way fargate is a
tool that will make your containers
behave like serverless functions
removing the need to allocate ec2
instances for your containers but if
you're building an application
and already have it containerized the
easiest way to deploy it to aws
is app runner this is a new product in
2021 where you simply point it to a
container image
while it handles all the orchestration
and scaling behind the scenes
but running an application is only half
the battle we also need to store data in
the cloud
simple storage service or s3 was the
very first product offered by aws
it can store any type of file or object
like an image or video
and is based on the same infrastructure
as amazon's ecommerce site
it's great for general purpose file
storage but if you don't access your
files very often
you can archive them in glacier which
has a higher latency but a much lower
cost
on the other end of the spectrum you may
need storage that is extremely fast and
can handle a lot of throughput
elastic block storage is ideal for
applications that have intensive data
processing requirements
but requires more manual configuration
by the developer now if you want
something that's highly performant and
also fully managed
elastic file system provides all the
bells and whistles but at a much higher
cost in addition to raw files
developers also need to store structured
data for their end users
and that brings us to the database aisle
which has a lot of different products to
choose from
the first ever database on aws was
simpledb
a general purpose no sql database but it
tends to be a little too simple for most
people
everybody knows you never go full [ __ ]
it was followed up a few years later
with dynamodb
which is a document database that's very
easy to scale horizontally
it's inexpensive and provides fast read
performance but it isn't very good at
modeling relational data
if you're familiar with mongodb another
document database option
is documentdb it's a controversial
option that's technically not mongodb
that has a one-to-one mapping of the
mongodb api
to get around restrictive open source
licensing speaking of which
amazon also did a similar thing with
elasticsearch which itself is a great
option if you want to build something
like a
full text search engine but the majority
of developers out there will
opt for a traditional relational sql
database
amazon relational database service rds
supports a variety of different sql
flavors
and can fully manage things like backups
patching and scale
but amazon also offers its own
proprietary flavor of sql called aurora
it's compatible with postgres or mysql
and can be operated with better
performance at a lower cost
in addition aurora offers a new
serverless option that makes it even
easier to scale
and you only pay for the actual time
that the database is in use
relational databases are a great general
purpose option but they're not the only
option
neptune is a graph database that can
achieve better performance on highly
connected data sets
like a social graph or recommendation
engine if your current database is too
slow you may want to bring in
elastic cache which is a fully managed
version of redis an
in-memory database that delivers data to
your end users with extremely low
latency if you work with time series
data
like the stock market for example you
might benefit from time stream
a time series database with built-in
functions for time-based queries
and additional features for analytics
yet another option
is the quantum ledger database which
allows you to build an immutable set of
cryptographically signed transactions
very similar to decentralized blockchain
technology
now let's shift gears and talk about
analytics to analyze data you first need
a place to store it and a popular
option for doing that is redshift which
is a data warehouse that tries to get
you to shift away from oracle
warehouses are often used by big
enterprises to dump multiple data
sources from the business where they can
be analyzed together when all your data
is in one place it's easier to generate
meaningful analytics and run machine
learning on it
data in a warehouse is structured so it
can be queried but if you need a place
to put a large amount of unstructured
data you can use aws
lake formation which is a tool for
creating data lakes or repositories that
store a large amount of
unstructured data which can be used in
addition to data warehouses to query a
larger variety of data sources
if you want to analyze real-time data
you can use kinesis to capture real-time
streams from your infrastructure then
visualize them in your favorite business
intelligence tool
or you can use a stream processing
framework like apache spark
that runs on elastic mapreduce which
itself is a service that allows you to
operate on massive datasets efficiently
with a parallel distributed algorithm
now if you don't want to use kinesis for
streaming data a popular alternative is
apache kafka
it's open source and amazon msk is a
fully managed service to get you started
but for the average developer all this
data processing may be a little too
complicated
glue is a serverless product that makes
it much easier to extract
transform and load your data it can
automatically connect to other data
sources on aws
like aurora redshift and s3 and has a
tool called glue studio
so you can create jobs without having to
write any actual source code but one of
the biggest advantages of collecting
massive amounts of data
is that you can use it to help predict
the future and aws has a bunch of tools
in the machine learning aisle to make
that process easier
but first if you don't have any high
quality data of your own
you can use the data exchange to
purchase and subscribe to data from
third-party sources
once you have some data in the cloud you
can use sagemaker to connect to it
and start building machine learning
models with tensorflow or pi torch
it operates on multiple levels to make
machine learning easier and provides a
managed jupyter notebook that can
connect to a gpu instance to train a
machine learning model then deploy it
somewhere useful
that's cool but building your own ml
models from scratch is still extremely
difficult if you need to do image
analysis
you may as well just use the recognition
api it can classify all kinds of objects
and images and is likely way better than
anything that you would build on your
own
or if you want to build a conversational
bot you might use lex which runs on the
same technology that powers alexa
devices
or if you just want to have fun and
learn how machine learning works you
might buy a deep racer device
which is an actual race car that you can
drive with your own machine learning
code
now that's a pretty amazing way to get
people to use your cloud platform
but let's change direction and look at a
few other essential tools that are used
by a wide variety of developers
for security we have im where you can
create rules and determine who has
access to what
on your aws account if you're building a
web or mobile app where users can log
into an account
cognito is a tool that enables them to
log in with a variety of different
authentication methods and manages the
user sessions for you
then once you have a few users logged
into your app you may want to send them
push notifications
sns is a tool that can get that job done
or maybe you want to send
emails to your users ses is the tool for
that now that you know about all these
tools you're going to want an
organized way to provision them cloud
formation is a way to create templates
based on your infrastructure
in yaml or json allowing you to enable
hundreds of different services with the
single click of a button from there
you'll likely want to interact with
those services from a front-end
application like ios
android or the web amplify provides sdks
that can connect to your infrastructure
from
javascript frameworks and other
front-end applications now the final
thing to remember
is that all this is going to cost you a
ton of money which goes directly to
getting jeff's rocket up so make sure to
use aws cost explorer and budgets if you
don't want to pay for these big bulging
rockets
that's the end of the video it took a
ton of work so please like and subscribe
to support the channel or become a pro
member at fireship io to get access to
more advanced content about building
apps in the cloud thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one